Can you move to Greenland and get a job?
I'm here with Ahmed
and he's from Sri Lanka
and he googled Greenland in 2020
because he was curious about the Inuit traditions.
And he saw my very first video on YouTube
and now he lives here and works at our hotel.
Ahmed, was it easy to move here?
I find a workplace in Greenland
and then I applied
and then this workplace specifically trusted me through
the Danish immigration system to get me here.
And it's very difficult to get an approval from
the Danish immigration system
when you farner without an EU passport.
So I've met,
did a lot of paperwork to get here.
It's not that called as people thinking here,
maybe it looks like isolated country,
but it was not an isolated country.
But people live here peacefully and quiet.
Life is amazing.
Okago tacos.